i have to say you look fantastic it's
incredible that you're managing to do
all of these things all at once how are
you doing
um you know well i went to bed at um
6 30.
my baby's teething right now so he's
having a little bit of a hard time
sleeping so i went to bed at 6 30 got my
two hours of sleep but i'm good to go
but i find that as moms we really
um are needing sleep less and less and
less and um so that's the most important
thing to me is is him and at the end of
the day i have an amazing makeup artist
so
yeah
throw it together in five minutes
makeup artists are just everything when
you're a new mother like it's they they
change the world they just do true it's
true
listen congratulations on becoming a mom
it's so fantastic what has surprised you
the most though about becoming a parent
the thing that surprised me the most
about becoming a parent was i didn't you
know i had heard from friends that you
know mothers are the most critical and
they will over analyze everything that
you do
and it wasn't until you know i gave
birth that i went through that process
and that was really difficult um the
most difficult part for me was you know
all these rumors going around about you
know me faking my pregnancy and that was
first of all i was i was so shocked
because i didn't see it coming and
i i mean you know it was extremely
hurtful considering you know the process
that i went through and i know you know
um
editing and you know chronological order
on the show it doesn't really
necessarily help
um because i had my baby and then i was
doing a yoga scene but in real life in
that yoga scene i was actually pregnant
um it's just they decided to bring
davina back at a certain time and that
was the producer's choice
so they edited me from
you know
the boobs up
so i got a lot of backlash on social
media saying you know i can't believe
you're doing yoga two weeks after you
know giving
birth and having an emergency c-section
when in reality i really haven't even
worked out to this day yet it took me
about four and a half months until i
could even
like touch my toes right yeah i had a
c-section too also twice so i understand
you can't you can't do those things
yeah absolutely and it's it was it was
really difficult because people don't
understand you know we shot the show
over six months you know and there's a
lot that goes into it and you know when
you see one episode to the next so much
time goes by so you know my process was
not easy by any means and on tv they
make it look easy but i was i was
struggling in real life i really was so
when you talk about that emotionally and
thank you for sharing that because i
know how difficult that could be who was
your rock who was your person who was
helping you up through through all of
that because that that's not only
dealing with being a new mom but also
then dealing publicly with
that sort of shame shaming or attempt at
shaming uh would be incredibly hard so
who was your person
uh my number one person was obviously my
husband and my family and then um you
know i leaned a lot on my co-stars
because you know maya and i got really
close through the pregnancy process
because she's been through it a lot
amanda as well um you know davina there
were you know people that were there for
me who you know saw me through the
process but you know number one was my
husband and um you know he was he was
definitely my rock and
um
he was the most supportive
that's amazing through a lot of this
season i mean they're always in every
good show there's always a villain and
right now that in that season that keeps
popping up that is a theme for you in
this season um what does it feel like to
have that label i suppose right now
you know it's funny i've i've always
loved being the villain but i feel like
you know we look at villains
like um you know
miranda priestly from the devil's prada
and you know she's fabulous and she's
glamorous and she says what she's want
and you know she says whatever she wants
and she's maybe short with people but
you know she's really good at her job
and you do see in the movie that she
really does have a heart and i think
that's what you know the storyline here
is is um
you know we need to get over this
narrative that just because women you
know
um say what's on their mind they're
strong they're powerful that their
chastise you know as the villain and
i believe that you know because i have
such quick wit and humor and i have fun
with it and i enjoy it and i love to
camp it up and glam it up it is a show
at the end of the day
but um you know i was really hoping that
there would be multiple sides to my
personality shown you know i just didn't
want to be a one-note villain but sure
um
so you know i can't that's why i'm
looking forward to my book because
that's a chance for me to tell my own
narrative
with you know with without editing
without you know any other extenuating
circumstances because there's always a
lot of and i don't think a lot of people
think of it now
there's always a lot of emotional
baggage outside of the show that never
used to be there maybe even five years
ago yeah it's a larger load to carry i
would imagine now with social media the
social media aspect of it you know
sometimes is what gets me down the most
because
um i
i i can't
i can't even fathom how
people take this show
so seriously you know at the end of the
day yes we're all real estate agents we
do work together but um you know you
have to realize the timeline that goes
into this like i said you know we shot
it in six months
everything that you see on the
television is not in chronological order
um you know we
put things into place so that it tells a
good story
and you know sometimes the narrative
doesn't really translate with viewers so
um you know
i i feel like you know i get so
frustrated because i want to address so
many things but i don't want to feel the
fire
and the biggest thing for me was you
know that started these pregnancy rumors
was you know
all of the fact that i was doing yoga
you know on headstands but in fact i was
really pregnant in that scene so
um you know i i um i wasn't i wasn't
happy with the producers and the way
that they put they portrayed that but
yeah so i understand they had an agenda
in bringing davina back when they wanted
to bring her back
and you know that's their choice but um
it was just not realistic you know i'm
i'm all about setting realistic
expectations for women but when you know
they're constantly talking about my body
and you know snapping back so quickly
yeah those are comments that i don't
necessarily want to hear and were really
uncomfortable for me at the time right
as a woman i don't think those are the
things that we should focus on i think
we should be focusing on mental health
are you okay how are you feeling you
know all these things and so there was
so much um
you know there was such a whirlwind
around my body
that and the yoga pose yeah yeah it just
it really you know it was hard to deal
with can i ask this that one of the the
band and not to give things away but
there was there was a confusion over
timelines with an ex
do you feel that the shooting of the
show is partially what threw those times
lines out for mary and the other women
when they were trying to understand or
where was that chronological mix-up well
the cl the chronological mix-up was um
i mean it came from so many different
places um we really didn't have a lot of
drama you know between the girls and i
we were actually all in a really really
good place and we needed to um mix the
cast up we needed some fresh blood we
needed some drama in the office so
they decide to
cast
a
real estate agent at the time who
you know had been around the oppenheim
group here and there but the producers
heard about her past and they said
we have something juicy here
so you know it's really hard when you're
doing a reality show because you know
you have to talk about things that you
don't want to talk about and sure you
know i was never the first one to bring
it up ever um
and the producers you know don't don't
do me any favors especially the dog
party i asked her you know i said
um
i said i wish you would have reached out
to me um i would have shown you text
messages receipts anything i would have
shown you that we were together at the
time i would have shown you anything and
in real life she responds i said why
didn't you reach out to me and in real
life she responds because i was too
afraid i didn't know what i was going to
see
but
the producers of course didn't want to
give me the benefit of the doubt as
usual
so they inter cut an interview clip of
her saying that
so i'm constantly
you know against editing
and um you know i did not know davina at
the time that i was dating him
um i did know mary
um i think towards the end
um i met mary i think when my
relationship was fizzling out towards
the end okay so um you know and it's
it's not who i am i don't talk about my
relationships i didn't announce i was
pregnant until i was six months um no
one knew i was even dating anyone until
i randomly was engaged to christian it's
just
you know um i'm not really a heather and
tarek you know if you want to put it
that way i don't
um i keep my private life really private
so um for me it was a really difficult
season because these are things i don't
want to talk about these are things i
don't care about in real life and having
to relive them and rehash them
um it's painful
it was it was painful and it was also
painful to watch
you know davina did defend me in real
life she told me and called me after the
scene and she said you know
christine told me this and i know you
know
i know what she told me
and um however i didn't know her back
then so it's just you're only seeing
bits and parts
um but you know i did my best with what
i was given and it was a hard season you
know there were six women ganging up on
me
um non-stop and it was you know i was i
was pregnant on top of dealing with
postpartum depression and the season was
really difficult for me so it was just
um
it was it was hard it was hard in a lot
of ways but you know i learned and i'm a
lot stronger because of it
you mentioned that you had postpartum
depression did that was that something
that you were vocal with with the other
women and with producers while you were
going through that absolutely absolutely
you know i had i had told them many
times you know and they make fun of the
fact of me being late in the show you
know oh christine's late oh christine's
late and it's because i was literally
having panic attacks and i was worried
about my pregnancy and something going
wrong because
every time i was working i was walking
into work it was a lion's den and
these girls were
you know pitted against me
and it was really really difficult so
when they say oh christine was late
three hours to a scene it was like yeah
because i was i was you know dealing
with position
i couldn't i couldn't deal with it and
um it was really really hard but you
know i i showed up i did my job and i
did the best that i could
um you know with the emotions that i was
dealing with at the time and that i'm
i'm still dealing with now you know yeah
no it doesn't go away it doesn't go away
after having read a baby and yeah and
and
you know
i know we're doing an interview here but
as long as you have a lot of support
around you and and good people to to
talk with
and keep talking that's the most
important thing right absolutely and i
it's you know it's something that i
really wasn't even wanting to talk about
in the first place because my birth was
so traumatic but yes so
um i found so many women who reached out
to me and said you know no one talks
about this no one talks about
um you know what you went through as
well you know um having you know a
c-section and it being so difficult i
think at the end of the day people don't
talk about the fact that there can be
some ptsd having after having a baby it
can be very traumatic to the body and to
the mind like it it just can and and not
everybody's birth is
rainbows and bunnies and butterflies
it's just not exactly yeah and the
problem that i was facing is you know
extrovertedly everyone was saying oh
well you know she's she's so she's so
thin she's so this she's so that but
inside you know i was dealing with ptsd
you're absolutely right and still to
this day you know i'm i'm working with
people to you know give back to the
person that i was good that's great do
you think outside of the show i mean you
mentioned that this is i know we have to
go i could talk to you for hours but
outside of the show um
you know this is a show this is a tv
show uh out of the show there is a place
for you and the women to truly be
friends and to to mend these things
that are that seem really big and
difficult right now
i believe that you know the other cast
members and you know my associates are
so caught up on
articles and things that they read and
they don't read the real story they only
read the headline
and so i would find these girls and i i
didn't know why they were mad at me the
entire season i'm like why are you so
mad at me and you know i found out it
was because they were reading you know
um amped up headlines but not even
really reading the actual article and so
you know i had a conversation with them
and i was like why are you mad at me and
they would say oh i saw this article and
i said
did you actually read the article
because the article you know i was
defending you and i was talking about
you but you know they only use
one clip because they want you know
click bait and i get all that but um
you know i saw mary and romaine at the
people's choice awards i thought oh did
you
how'd that go it was great you know um
mary said hi i gave her a hug romaine as
well um tarek was actually you know
really kind and nice to me and you know
heather heather was nice to me as well
so i feel like outside of the show
we actually get along really well
that's good
it's just you know when when we're
filming a television show
it's a little lamped up i get it well i
just want to say thank you for your
honesty i really do appreciate it i know
that that is not easy and we just wish
you lots of love with that beautiful
baby and your family
and uh one day hopefully we'll get to
talk in person you too yes this is so
wonderful and thank you so much i cannot
wait to come and see you guys in person
hopefully absolutely definitely all
right well we'll go baby shopping when
we come in la nick i would love that